what's up guys
we're doing this we're watching brooklyn
nine-nine oh look out now yeah
we're we're back we're back to watch
back in the shack i think it's 13 of
season three
yes
lucky number ladies and gentlemen leave
a like please hooray for the love of god
leave a like please like us subscribe
and click that notification bell for
crying out loud
for super sexy rejects this show we do
full length reaction watch along as we
sync up with the time code
apparently a lot of people don't know
that
when we say that
yes syncing up with the time code means
you will provide your own copy that's at
a patreon that's a patron
and boys at prepper thanks for helping
us edit this down
all right let's see what jake
and the gang what jake lloyd and andre
brauer have for us today
roll that intro
you sure you're cool keeping tabs on my
cases while i'm on the cruise you bet i
hope you have a great time don't make
any new best friends
[Laughter]
uh maybe you shouldn't go
[Laughter]
who's ready for some non-stop totally
scheduled fun i actually thought we
could just sit by the pool eat unlimited
shrimp and see what it does to our
bodies i don't know if there's gonna be
time though the crews offer 77
activities and i signed us up for 76 of
them are you trying to break up with
them slightly different perspectives
going into this cruise call it the slug
life talking but i think it's going to
work itself out goodbye co-workers or as
they like to say at c
[Music]
classic cartoon sound effects
say i love carousel cruises
international ltd
i love carousel cruises internationally
i don't want to say that
the sail away party is in an hour and
until then i have a schedule to take in
live music at the all ages piano lounge
yeah buddy the all ages piano lounge has
bottomless margarita they also have a
drink with a potato skin in it to the
all ages piano lounge murderer
why would you not want to do things on
the cruise ladies and gentlemen
but especially ladies
[Music]
i can't believe he's here i've been
hunting him for years and now fate has
dropped him right into my lap he's gonna
be so surprised when he sees me hey
peralta you made it
okay he seems like he's playing it
pretty cool probably more surprised on
the inside huh
[Music]
love how they incorporated that he
actually plays piano in real life
hurricane debbie my little sister debbie
she's a real drama queen
i'm a queen of the holt family what did
she laugh out loud one time she's
laughed out loud multiple times
once i used an exclamation point in the
email you called me diana ross i assure
you in this case i do not exaggerate
raymond oh no that sounds awful i swear
to you i heard the cab driver mumble
under his breath you will die tonight is
that not the most insane thing you have
ever heard i mean can you even raymond i
cannot even
[Laughter]
neesee nash she was 89 years old there's
no forced entry or visible trauma it's
probably natural causes we'll take a
look around sure this huge apartment
what is this like 1800 square feet oh my
god it'd be on sale right now with a
dead body this is an opportunity you
just don't get new york real estate ever
a woman just died here don't be gross
and disrespectful holy crap look at all
this closet space i'm applying to what
you don't need closet space roommates we
saw it at the same time may the best man
win game on
i mean the game of contacting the next
of kin that's the game i like to play
yes good cover on a free cruise without
entering a contest how do you think that
happened i don't know maybe it's because
i bought speed two on dvd and the
internet realized that cruises were one
of my interests great film sandy being a
sarong damn straight
[Laughter]
apparel don't my peril somebody's trying
to kill me and i need protection so i
set for my best friend i am not your
best friend i'm your worst enemy get
that through your head
you're under arrest you can't arrest me
boo we're in international waters which
is also why i can smoke as much weed as
i want yeah to the high seas
judy's right we have no jurisdiction
technically this boat flies under the
flag of uzbekistan uh-oh your girl knows
about the oozebacks oozbix
the captain can have him arrested he has
total authority on this boat
perfect captains love me just wait until
he or she finds out they're employing a
criminal yeah about 40 of the crew are
criminals
people who want to live on a boat i
myself am a tax evader i just need them
locked up till we get back to new york
can't you just throw them in boat jail
it's called the brig
oh
oh no
listen as long as he's on my boat doug
judy is a free man
dude just help him jake amy welcome to
my cabin aka the boom boom stateroom
if i could whistle i would
little perk of being carousel cruisers
entertainer of the year which i am girl
pitchy you're welcome to chill here this
protection scam is a scam do you
honestly think you can fool me again
just because you've successfully done it
numerous times before
she accused of stealing a hairbrush
she's on the phone screaming at our
mother we'll keep her out of your hair
i'm good at distracting people it's what
i do with my toddlers all day long how
does she feel about balloon animals i'm
sure she has a complicated relationship
with him
yes i'd love to discuss your hair brush
for even more time but i have some
pressing police matters to attend to
look at you always working what happened
to my fun big brother fine i was never
found you take that back
[Laughter]
we would stay down there all day and ray
was singing these silly little made-up
songs george and ira gershwin did not
compose silly made-up songs uh debbie
let me show you new york okay the
building's the subway the bank no
oh that's a great idea gina debbie i'm
so sorry i i won't get a chance to see
you much on your visit nothing but a
chicken wing cause i'm gonna be here for
six weeks i'm gonna be all up in your
luck oh my god
even i'm
getting anxiety
henry street and cole street that's the
corner of your old chop shop in brooklyn
he's hiding somewhere on this boat ready
to jump out and kill me at any moment
probably creeping around in my closet
they're stowed away in a lifeboat or
hiding in a wall or holed up in the
engine room camouflage in the shrubbery
predator style nope we are not having
fun you will not suck me in with your
wily charms
can i talk to rosa for a quick sec about
some super serious police work i know
what you're trying to do you brought him
in here to butter him up yeah and i've
been laying it on
real
sick
mint
okay
[Laughter]
bring it okay
looks like you and i are in a good
old-fashioned suck-off don't call it a
suck-off why not why shouldn't oh yeah
yeah
beatrice
don't want to mess with another man's
tang there's no way they're called tangs
it's true they are and the discs are
called biscuits tangs and biscuits that
is so dumb
i officially love shuffleboard
there's a hitman on this boat i'm henry
cole according to my medical alert
bracelet this is henry coles let's just
take a look at that oh it says doug judy
is a liar actually it says i'm a fall
risk kind of ruining my burn here henry
i knew it
damn it henry we're spending the rest of
this trip in your cabin amy and i will
take sleep shifts to make sure someone's
always watching you it makes me feel
super safe fine i get it he's the
pontiac bandit
hey
daddy believe me that guy was trying to
kill me all right fine someone wants you
dead you win
[Laughter]
we still don't know what your hitman
looks like so we're gonna have to flush
him out wait a minute where did the
toilets on this boat go you don't want
to know
the pool ocean oh that's even worse
that's where my shrimp live
[Music]
all right here's the plan we're gonna
leave you alone on stage and dangle you
as bait damn bait dangling we'll blend
into the crowd and we'll take him down
before he even gets to you
all right i'll trust you but if you're
gonna blend in you got to blend in if
you like
oh
yeah
blending in and i feel like i'm jimmy
buffett's tennis coach no it's working
you know i had a major crush on magnum
p.i
major
oh you found me
drinking seltzer in the shadows
debbie's going to be staying with me for
six weeks sir when your neighbor is
playing their terrible music too loud do
you ask them to be quiet hell no you
blast your garbage and you drown em out
you gotta fight drama with drama
fascinating hey man i'm leaving for
paris
and i said
then go already i don't care but i do
care and now i'm like
where's kevin well i didn't know y'all
had all that going on
no one understands me
and now you're here and i love you
but like
it's a lot
everything in my life is a hot mess
the commissioner called again he wants
to know when crime will be down are you
kidding me what am i supposed to tell
him you got a lot on you and i don't
want to overstay my welcome if that's
going to stress you out especially with
mercury in retrograde
yes sir
i didn't know i mean the only reason i
came is
cause gary left me
oh no
but you know what
no no no i'm not gonna burden you with
that okay i will deal with that myself
there has been a jail break and the
mafia is at it again
damn mafia kataro
isn't that a andalusian name yeah last
night i cooked up a ton of andalusian
baby eel i love angula i mean it's
impossible to find here not if you have
a ton of disposable income and great
credit like i do
you have great
and disposable income i should tell you
you're both great applicants but i've
decided to rent the apartment to someone
else i smiled at you for what
widows and widowers
welcome to the all ages piano lounge
adults only show
[Music]
oh
right there on the floor is the man
you're looking for
he's right in front of you
a little bit to the left my left my left
my left
he's in a red church
no not the asian dude
i'm talking about a bright red shirt
that's the man you're looking for that's
the man you've been looking for i got a
[ __ ] love song people come on
no
where'd he go
all of a sudden you've been a great
crowd oh
no jake help me i don't want to die i'm
still on second season game of thrones
all right let's just put the knife
that's still good there's no murder in
the all ages piano lounge screw you pig
that is not a very all ages thing to say
you just don't get the vibe here at all
yeah
grab that cord let's get his arms
come here you just got tanged by my
girlfriend sorry i know that sounded
really gross but it was actually awesome
you okay judy
coward shooty
oh no
[Music]
thanks for saving my life no
judy don't do this no not again
where's judy going to go there must be
an escape boat he's just gonna swim off
into the sunset
man i saw an opening and i had to take i
can't go to jail i'm too cool you'll
never get away from me judy i'll just
assume you're finally admitting we're
best friends no that is not what i'm
saying thank you
i will hunt you to the ends of the earth
i love you too
i'm so proud of us for being able to say
it
well but my train is in 45 minutes i
don't have to say goodbye to ray i don't
want to stress him out no he
specifically asked us to get you
hello debbie oh
i want you to know that i'm here for you
and i would love to be
all up in your life
[Laughter]
you're under arrest for the murder of
your tenant shirley crouch if you go to
jail who makes the rental decisions in
the building it'll pass to a trust the
bank controls it getting back on if you
have to ask you're already one step
behind
i should help bring them back in we're
still police officers
[Laughter]
priorities
you'll never guess what starts in three
minutes salsa dancing oh so you can
guess
oh yeah
thank you for doing this
i love you
noise no
i love you too
[Music]
oh
[Music]
also i think this is definitely a dance
class for widows
no oh no no now turn to your partner and
tell them how your spouse died yeah we
should get out of here are you sure
okay oh god hey plus
a plus
damn want to hear all those all those
spousal death stories
well that was way better than the hunter
hunter episode we watched earlier
come on over to patreon and check that
out and see if we're lying
nice little pick-me-up it was a delight
that was a lovely episode
yes it was john
yes it was yes you are that craig t
nelson am i
right correcting nelson's never been
funnier never been more smooth never
been more musical this hot tub time
machine he's great in the devil's
advocate too
poltergeist and uh
yeah
oh man this is the end and also
and um um and the voice in the
incredibles yes definitely okay craig
tina's craig t nelson man i love him
love all of his work
all this work all this work man
that's funny they are they are like best
friends they really are
yeah i could see it heartwarming
they need that tension
i know hope me help me by the end of
this series they'll realize or jake will
realize the truth it'd be fun to have a
friend like him mm-hmm get you on
all those rules about the cruise true
because damn that's awesome
about being in international waters and
stuff and then yeah you can
be a criminal be out there why don't
more criminals escape out there maybe
they do and i didn't know that
i would look into this i mean i think
international waters and you know the
lack of jurisdiction is certainly a
thing yeah
there's definitely places in the world
you can go to get away from johnny law
there's an interesting a b story there
with the
you know holt and the sister
both dealing with
individuals who they
kind of intervening in their
life at the time
not a routine for jake and amy but
they're just trying to do their thing
and here they are
having to deal with something else some
other individual
someone who keeps popping in
keeps bringing drama but
i like that storyline quite a bit i
would love to go on a cruise here been
on a cruise we've been a cruise never
been on a cruise damn your family sucks
all right man
my family took me on cruises all the
time we didn't go to europe we didn't
take a cruise
travel the world we haven't been to
live in america florida hello america
take a trip to other parts that are not
america you sucker i would love to
that's why we're here we're all rich in
america that's right all of us when you
when you become an american uncle sam
stops by with ten thousand dollars it's
true man if you're not from america you
don't know what you're missing out on
all that free money free money dude lots
of public services it's great that are
in good repair i've never been on a
cruise i don't know what it's like um
i've been on a boat before but never
wanted that's almost the same exact
thing in some ways
but i don't want to do all the
activities why would you just want to
sleep but knowing me but yeah i would
probably want to spend my first day just
sleeping see that's what's handy is that
if it's like a week long then yeah you
can do that for a day or even two days
if you're really just like siesta ing
and then still have time to be like oh
there's there's stuff to do there's
experiences to have there's
the world to behold you know i think
there's an adam sandler movie about a
murder on a cruise ship that sounds like
a movie worth watching
that we should react is it on a cruise
ship i don't think it's on a cruise ship
i'm gonna google it
google it
we'll see it's one of the ones with
jennifer aniston
yeah it's called murder mystery is
murder mystery on a cruise i don't think
so i think i'm just remembering it
incorrectly
i'm searching out there
no faster no dead beats no spaces here
no spaces in a youtube video branson
luke evans falls to marry a couple up in
a murder investigation on a
billionaire's yacht
so you know not not exactly one for one
but very close very very close very
close being close is good almost a yacht
is like a cruise but way more exclusive
john being on a boat is like being on a
cruise so me being on a boat is more
akin to me being on a yacht which then
multiplied by many hundreds of you know
feet and people and and dimensions then
is it is the cruise and that's six
degrees of separation from kevin bacon
right there and then terry crews is a
part of this show's cast yeah so um
six degrees of kevin bacon yeah
uh uh this was this was a delight i i
feel like
this was almost like two episodes
in a sense i well it's funny because
yeah it's like the the the the jake and
amy story and the whole story have this
sort of very like connecting tissue
that makes a lot of sense and then in a
sense you could say that the whole story
and the rosa and
and charles story are kind of off in
their own corner too
look john i know i laid down during our
famous hunter hunter reaction
yeah it was some of the best reviewing
you've done that's because i was like
like almost so relaxed over this episode
but i'm just genuinely really tired so
i'm gonna just lay down okay yeah talk
yeah
absolutely do what you got to do
i'll grab a a little bit of floor we
have headphones now so it's fine yeah
yeah we can hear each other the audio
will be just it's going to be exactly
the same isn't that amazing yeah
yeah oh it's much better oh [ __ ] oh yeah
that really hits this button
you do it good
job i want you to tell me about jake and
amy like close my eyes oh yeah jake and
amy i mean i really liked that they
didn't go like i i liked the tension
that they did with jake and amy and
and doug judy because
this is like i'm on the best phone call
with you
like damn that audio is great yeah right
yeah
dude we should we should find a way to
hook these up to our phones and maybe
we'll have three hour phone calls here
if we used to
um but i like the jake and amy story
having the obvious tensions but not
succumbing in the obvious way to those
tensions which made for a very sweet
results like you have doug judy to
distract from jake's
you know
looseness and amy's
scheduled rigidity
and then by the end they're able to meet
in the middle in a very lovely and
graceful way and i thought this was
going to be one of those episodes where
it's like oh this might not end up good
but then it did they said they loved
each other that's a good point because
normally you would probably expect some
big blowout fighter like this is
supposed to be yeah this is supposed to
be our trip and you're making this about
it's like it's like the script cracker
right just a [ __ ] psychological
relationship drama
yes with jake and amy quarantined on a
boat yeah and this is this about the
relationship is using judy has an excuse
to get get away because he's avoiding
because the intimacy that's why he says
things like smart and noise
because he can't he can't just deal with
being vulnerable and dealing with his
feelings
um but that's not where this episode
went at all
yeah it's like you can you can read
little things like that in the subtext
and in the performances and whatnot but
i liked yeah they that they it felt more
real because of that it felt like this
sort of okay
this isn't quite going as well as it
should be but everyone's kind of trying
to make it work and then by the end they
they do in a way that's still kind of
dramatically satisfying that was really
touching with holt and his sister oh
that could have been uh that could have
been like i feel like the storyline was
so
brief and yeah it had such a heartfelt
moment and i'm like if we were there
like 30 seconds longer i might have
cried i know i was thinking that too i
was i was starting to well up and and
and and that's the thing is i feel like
because you have doug judy back you have
an interestingly shaped episode that
that i think turned out
a lot better than i would have expected
on paper because yeah like
the the halt and the
charles and rosa storylines do feel
much more compact by comparison
and yet
both of them but especially the whole
one by the end you're like that was
really lovely
you know so true
so true i mean rosa rosen charles more
just like fun like that's the most like
fun and wacky of all the the
story lines and then yeah the whole one
i thought was really lovely and i love
niecy nash as his sister i thought she's
great choice yeah
and i don't understand how
um
oh my god i'm forgetting his name boyle
how he has
passive income and good credit with all
the financial woes he's expressed in the
past episodes i get
i would peg him as somebody who has
decent credit but i would never peg him
somebody with disposable link but he
said he gives like 80 percent of his
salary or something to his ex his
ex-wife and
and i'm like no way this guy is good
credit
yeah i mean probably maxes out his cards
every month or something yeah i'm like
are we are we are we uh
is there something we're forgetting
where they like resolved that somehow
cops don't make that much money yeah
jesus
but then maybe maybe he just has good
credit because he makes small purchases
and pays them off fast i just think
there's so many consistencies here in
the flop dude the
something about her she is a presence to
behold it's like
what's her name
melissa leo
marissa told me
what's her name
for romeo
the one
who plays amy melissa famero
i believe that's her name
like she's more like the traditional hot
but something about stephanie beatrice
i'm like i don't know what it is about
you but
you're kind of lady
yeah i mean
she's got i don't know and especially in
an episode like this where you know you
got tough rosa but then she's turning on
like very appealing persuasive rosa like
it's
yeah like that manipulation
it works it works in real time even
whilst watching it in a sitcom
ah good episode all right guys well
thanks for being here
you should go ahead subscribe
click that bell
leave a like
hey john why don't we do a patron of the
day
of the day shot here i'll join you on
the floor for this [ __ ]
scuba steve
what to say what to say about you you
might not know why we're not in frame
but we're here we're do you see us we're
here we're here buddy because you
probably just skipped here
it's been a long day scuba
lissa like you buddy we're underwater
right now see how we did that we're
underground
oh my god we're scuba diving
lung capacity like tom cruise scooby's
been with us for so long i
i can't imagine what it's like to be
pledged to a person's patreon for this
long yeah scoobs what's wrong with you
you're just like it's just one of those
things i do know you know like there's
so many bills i pay that i'm just like
ah [ __ ] are you forgetting to cancel
that yes whatever the amount of apps on
my phone and then i'm like goddamn it i
just okay just make sure when's my next
subscription i could just cancel this
subscription now but i'll just wait till
closer to the date i forgot again
it's okay and uh i think that's been you
you're getting for like a couple years
natural and human and we benefit from
your forgetfulness oh it's just great
that you've been here for the amount of
time you've been here man and yeah let's
go on a cruise together i really
appreciate you brother thank you let's
be in the water you're uh
one of the kind you're so cool steve
enough
that's half your name in spanish and
half of it in english
i think scuba would probably still be
the same in spanish so because it's an
acronym
that's uh
el
you're you're good you're a good guy
never leave scoobs